Fidel Castro a fait son entrée triomphal
à La Havane il y a un peu plus d'un an
lorsqu'une force anti-castriste tente un
débarquement dans la baie des Cochons au
sud de l'île
la tentative d'invasion se transforme en
désastre
sur la côte dans les marais des cadavres
d'envahisseurs
échec embarrassant pour John Kennedy qui
vient d'assumer la présidence américaine
[Applaudissements]
convaincu que les Américains volent
encore prendre l'île par la force et
qu'ils veulent l'assassiner fidèle
Castro se tourne vers l'Union soviétique
Cuba bascule dans le camp communiste
a décidé d'installer du matériel
militaire sur les documents à la fois
pour protéger l'île et évidemment en
même temps pour mettre un pied si on
veut en terre en terre américaine dans
le sens continental du terme donc en
octobre en octobre
62 il y a des missiles qui sont
installés à Cuba et la ciae prend des
photos et conclut qu'effectivement il y
a une menace réelle à ce moment-là pour
les États-Unis les Soviétiques ont mis
le paquets 45 ogives nucléaires vise la
Floride à moins de 150 km des côtes
42000 soldats soviétiques sont déployés
sur l'île avec soutien de régiment
d'infanterie de 41 mig quatre vaisseaux
de guerre et ont sous-marin alors c'est
la consternation et évidemment il y aura
des réactions forts différentes au sein
de l'administration Kennedy à ce
moment-là sur la des choses qu'est-ce
qu'on fait comment on réagit on ne peut
pas les laisser là la flotte et
l'aviation américaine sont en état
d'alerte ayant exigé de La Havane de
démantèlement des bases de fusée le
président Kennedy décide d'établir une
quarantaine autour de Cuba
il y a des faucons dans le camp
américain des militaires voudraient
bombarder les missiles soviétiques
envahir l'île pendant 13 jours la menace
nucléaire pèse sur toute l'Amérique du
Nord fidèle Castro et Che Guevara sont
prêts au sacrifice ultime
en particulier a fait beaucoup de
lobbying si on peut dire auprès des
crochets pour qu'il utilise l'arme
nucléaire contre les Américains parce
qu'ils disaient ils sont une menace
constante pour nous ils l'ont trouvé
dans le passé
John Kennedy son frère Robert les
diplomates préfèrent la négociation
secrète avec Nikita cruchov
[Musique]
d'un bluff énorme c'est une grande
partie de poker ah oui absolument c'est
vraiment un coup de dés que Kennedy a
décidé de faire parce qu'il était
persuadé que quoi que ce soit d'autre
mènerait à la catastrophe nucléaire
alors c'est tout à fait un pari qui
aurait pu être perdu mais heureusement
que chef aussi visiblement avait cette
volonté d'éviter l'escalade mais alors
que Castro est prêt à vaincre ou à périr
le danger mortel que court le monde
pousse le président Kennedy et Monsieur
couche sauf à s'entendre directement les
bases de fusée seront démantelées
monsieur mikaian fait part à Fidel
Castro de la décision du Kremlin et
obtient son accord non sans peine
fidèle Castro en gardera une grande
amertume en échange les États-Unis ont
accepté de retirer leur missile
nucléaire braquer vers Moscou en Turquie
mais l'accord restera secret ce qui
donnera l'impression que le vainqueur
c'est Kennedy et crowdf et le perdant
mais le monde est sauvé
le mieux communiquer qu'il va aller
mieux négocier qui va aller mieux
trouver des terrains d'entendre donc
cette détente là va durer jusqu'en 1979
jusqu'à l'invasion de l'Afghanistan par
les Soviétiques
au tout dernier moment un avion espion
américain est abattu au dessus de Cuba à
nouveau le monde retient son souffle
mais la raison prévôt et la corde